Elbow's name is
way
50.
This is
the
of the
school of
school.
Ib
the
from Ib M
when the
expanded
as governors or MUI. or what have you
in the various lands and those who came
around people mustered around those
companions right and it formed a school
in each of those regions. Sob Abbas was
dispatched to Mecca rightb
was dispatched to Abdahbn
was dispatched to
also
and etc.
He says,
"I was behind the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam meaning in writing behind him
one day and he said to me
is preubescent." This is said to a child
that has not yet reached the age of pub
puberty usually before the age of 10. So
we know that Abbass was very young when
this exchange happened.
He said, "I'm going to teach you some
doesn't mean some words. I'm going to
teach you some realities, some truths.
The truths about this world.
the reason people behave the way they
do is because of beliefs that they have,
right? What is the root of all evil?
Huh?
And disbelief in judgment the day of in
the day of judgment that is the root of
all evil. You know what they say, money
is the root of all evil. No, money is
neutral. It's a It's a tool.
It's as neutral as any inanimate object.
However, this tool is highly desirable.
And so, it brings out the best in some
and the worst in many. And so, the root
of all evil is disbelief in Allah in the
last day. Shik is a type of disbelief.
even if you believe even if a person
believes in resurrection but their
belief is a skewed it's wrong it's
incorrect their vision of what the day
of resurrection is is distorted
whatever a person believes is how their
actions and their behavior will follow
too much hope they will become very lax
and passive they have too much fear it
will break them and So if we want to
correct actions, we have to correct the
belief systems. That is how we correct
things. for instance, a lot of
times
when we see for instance certain
behaviors amongst the Muslim, we say we
need to have a about lying
as if there's a Muslim alive who doesn't
know that lying is wrong. as if there's
a human being alive that doesn't know
that lying is wrong. This is not an
issue of lack of knowledge. This is an
issue of lack of understanding. There's
a root cause here. Just hearing Allah
said don't lie and the prophet said
don't lie. This isn't this is not
enough. We have to address the
underlying illness.
If you had a doctor that you went to and
you said, "Doctor, I have a fever.
and I've had this fever for a month. I
don't know what's going on. Fear there's
really something wrong. He says, "Okay,
here's what we're going to do. Take
aspirin and get rid of the fever." I
mean, that that's it. That's his that's
his that's the epitome of his of his
medicine, his administration of remedy
to you. Would you be very happy with
that, doctor? Huh? But he got rid of the
fever, right? That's that's how we do
things in America. We just treat the
symptoms. We don't worry about what's
underlying, right? We have we have,
for instance, tragedies that happen.
We just make more laws and put more
police. You know what? It's better.
Let's have 10 police officers for every
citizen. That way, no one will do
anything wrong anymore. Why did
prohibition fail in America? Why did
prohibition fail? Is it because the
government wasn't strong enough? Was it
not mighty enough? Did they not have
enough money? No. It's because the
belief system of the citizenship did not
agree fundamentally
with the prohibition of alcohol. That's
why you could never prohibit something
that and have it be successful.
That's a symptom.
And that's why alcohol wasn't prohibited
in Islam in the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam's time until almost 20
years after the first message. Why?
Because the belief system had to change
in order for alcohol to become something
that people would respond to. Otherwise,
if if people do not believe something,
no matter how hard you bring down the
hammer, no matter how
heavy your iron fist as a government, as
a government, people will always find a
way to wiggle through the fingers, to
wiggle through the the bars, to
figure out how to break the law. And
that's why Islam is not based on
governance. It's based on
self-governance.
We change each individual people, each
individual family. You don't have to
watch every person and set up cameras in
every single room of their house and
figure out ways to monitor everyone day
and night. You don't have to do that
because the people themselves will
govern themselves. Right? And so Islam
is about addressing the underlying
illnesses, not about addressing the
symptoms. We look at this narration.
This narration here will solve
90% or say 70%
of all misunderstanding that our young
ch men and young women have. When
children grow up watching Disney movies
and watching, you know, for a person to
watch something that, it's going to
happen. That's that's not the issue
here. The issue is when that is all that
they have as a source of knowledge
and the idea is
there might be a god. This is what this
is what society is saying but not really
saying it outright. There might be a god
but you can't really be sure. But
anyways you don't know miss out on this
life. So you're a princess, you're a
prince, you're meant for great things.
everyone else is just a side character
in your in your epic you know in your
epic tale and you're the main character
of everything. Everything's going to ma
it's just going to work out. there is
some soulmate girl out there that's
going to come into your life and she is
going to just be perfect and
everything's going to be perfect and
you're the princess and you're Cinder
Cinderella and there's some prince out
there with a glass shoe that's going
to come and put it on your little foot
and everything's going to be great after
that. And then when they don't get that
25 30 years old, they're waiting for
that. They're waiting for that and then
what happens? They start to realize, "Oh
my gosh, I've been duped. This isn't
going to happen." Then what happens?
Depression, alcoholism, drug addiction,
suicide,
, etc., etc., etc. That's that is the
underlying issue here. Ultraviolence.
If we watch if we have children
watching movies and watching programs
that disrespect the human body and the
human form so much that it's not just
you know in the 80s or the 70s you
know a guy gets shot he oh you know and
falls down that was it that that was the
movie. No, now blood is showering the
whole place and smashing someone's head
until it's into little bits and so
forth. This kind of stuff is making
people sick.
It's making them sick. And so what
happens now is when people grow up
watching these things, this has attached
itself to their minds in a subconscious
way or a conscious way. And now we want
to try to catch up policing everything
to try to lower the symptoms just like
that doctor who only gives you aspirin
for your month-long
fever. Right here the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam is teaching the building
blocks that address many of these
things. This is a young man, a young
boy. Listen to what he's teaching him.
He says to him,
I'm going to teach you some truths,
some truths, some trueisms.
He says, "Preserve Allah's boundaries
and Allah will preserve you."
Preserve Allah
in his commands, in his commandments,
and you will find him in front of you
wherever you turn.
Listen to how he is teaching the
children. So the first thing, preserve
Allah and he will preserve you. What
does the child understand from this?
It's not this is a two-way street,
right? This is a two-way street. Allah
reciprocates.
It's not just he hears you and sits by
passively. No, your Lord reciprocates.
If you preserve his him in his
commandments, he will preserve you.
What's the opposite meaning? If you do
not preserve him in his commandments, he
will not preserve you. Right? He says,
"Preserve Allah and his commandments and
his boundaries and he and you will find
him in front of you wherever you go. He
will lead you down that path at every
turn in life in the depths of the
darknesses
of the belly of the whale or the
darkness of that prison that Ysef was
put into and forgotten by all of the
world.
Forgotten by all of the world. Yet
who knew that Ununus was in the belly of
a whale? Who knew that he was there? Let
alone is going to come to his rescue. No
one. But he says Allah says
he called out from the darknesses
and Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says that
Allah says that had he not been of those
who make not in the belly. This verse
doesn't mean he made in the belly
made tas before he was swallowed by the
whale. Is there any human being alive
that would get swallowed by a whale that
would not make?
There's nothing unique about that. You
get swallowed by a whale, the the most
staunch atheist on earth gets swallowed
by a whale, he's going to call out,
"Please, God save you." Right? That's
not unique. It's not that when he was
swallowed by the whale, he made tia. No,
no, no. The verse means had he not been
of those who made before he was
swallowed by the whale. He had an
account with Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala,
a relationship that he had built before
he made the mistake.
And so therefore, when he called out
in the midst of the consequence of one
of his mistakes, Allah answered. And so
he says,
notice this is a little kid. He's
teaching him short sentences that will
stick in his mind. He may not understand
every single sentence at this moment,
but they're easy to memorize and they
will stick in his mind and as he grows
they will grow. His understanding of
them will grow with the with them. He
says
if you ask ask Allah
and if you seek help seek help in Allah
we will take a stop there inshallah
we'll continue this tomorrow.
[Silence]
Okay.